of uh boot camp for the this program
um just wanted a few quick announcements
about the schedule so we'll have two
talks this morning on graph linear
algebra
um we're gonna have a lunch break and
we'll have two talks in the afternoon
one on um uh graph data structures and
then another on fine grain complexity
that'll be I think a little synergistic
with the one on graph data structures
that'll conclude the schedule for the
day but you should all look at the
schedule that'll conclude boot camp for
the day but there'll be some
refreshments after the last talk
followed by a theoretical uh speaking
seminar
um so that's it for today oh before I
forget
um if you have a question during the
talk and it's a slightly like longer
question that might be good to have them
like if you pause for a second I will
run over with a mic
um so friendly reminder of that anyway
without further
Ado Sean
thank you Aaron and thank you all for
coming for this uh for this first
morning talk uh
let me quickly tell you what every what
we're going to cover today I'd initially
thought planned that I would continue on
the theme of yesterday we'll talk about
eigenvalues
and eigenvectors how do they relate to
graph connectivity triggers inequality
if you've heard of it
I decided to drop that entirely and
instead present present something
somewhat more modern there are lots of
amazing treatments of cheetah online
already
so I'm not sure I would have done a
great Justice to it but I would also it
would also be a disservice if nobody at
this boot camp spoke about graph LaPlace
in solvers uh because in some sense this
many of us Trace at least the origins of
many of these ideas back to uh back to a
really fantastic work by Spillman and
Tang back in 2004 about solving
laplacian linear systems and I want to
build towards presenting
an algorithm a fast algorithm for
solving LaPlace and linear systems today
I think I should be able to give you an
entire proof but if not I will
definitely present you in an entire
algorithm
and ideas for how to prove Us in
right so before that in the first part
we'll begin with graph specification
linear algebraic drops falsification and
in the second half we'll work towards
LaPlace in solving LaPlace in linear
systems
right and as always
any questions please feel free to stop
me uh
these will be like uh faster than
yesterday second and the third a little
faster but I still
believe it's at a level where where
everyone should be following so please
stop me for questions
right uh please don't hesitate thank you
awesome so so let's dive in so so the
first part we're going to talk about
spectral graphs classification uh for
those of you new to the area maybe these
words make no sense but hopefully by the
end of the first R they will
super so sorry
it's just not working
yeah the clicker's not working but maybe
let's get started so I will here's
here's the result we will see today it's
a it's a result by spinman and Shiva
Savar 2008 uh that shows uh a linear
algebraic approach
to sparsifying graphs while preserving
cut structure this is an informal
statement I will formalize this
right so it was the result in 2008 and
it's uh in some sense a very simple
result it was one of the
yes you'll see as one of the results
that really shows you the power of
looking at graphs linear algebraic
and how some things fall out very very
naturally when you look at these
grassling algebraically
so let me do a quick recap of what we
defined yesterday so we Define what
positive semi-definite matrices so we'll
we say a matrix symmetric Matrix a so a
square symmetric Matrix a is PST
positive semi definite if its quadratic
form is always non-negative
and in particular this implies that all
your eigenvalues are non-negative
right we we defined this yesterday
and because of the quadratic form of the
laplacians laplacians are PC
the quadratic form of laplacians was Sum
over edges weight of the edge times x u
minus x v squared
always non-negative
so
building on PST matrices let me Define a
notion of approximation for PST matrices
it turns out to be very nice for for
dealing with them I'll Define a Epsilon
approximates B think of both as p is
square symmetric PhD matrices
I'll say that a Epsilon approximates B
if let's parse this the quadratic form
of a
is always sandwiched between the like a
small multiplicative Factor
times the quadratic form of B so it's
upper bounded by e to the Epsilon which
is roughly 1 plus Epsilon times
X transpose BX and lower bounded by e to
the minus Epsilon
times x transpose BX
right this should be true for every X so
the quadratic forms are sandwiched the
other way to think about it is that PhD
matrices actually
identify ellipsoids if I look at
if I look at the set
I I wanted to do a 3D 3D image of this
but it was uh more trickier to generate
so I'm going to draw it here so if I
look at the set X transpose ax is equal
to 1.
right it identifies a surface in N
Dimension right which is an ellipse oil
with the eigen with the eigen basis of a
giving you the principal axis of the
ellipsoid and the eigenvalue is
determining
the scale along the principal axis right
so in three dimension or two Dimensions
you can think of I mean it should be a
symmetric one my drawing skills are not
that great so
something like this right and when I say
A and B Epsilon approximate each other
you should think of them as follows that
there are these two ellipsoids
they don't have to be aligned right
but if I look at any direction
this is your X
then the point at which they intersect
along this line they are within 1 plus
minus Epsilon of each other
in all directions
yes does this definition make sense of
approximating PhD matrices
like con approximating convex bodies if
you the other way to think of it is if I
scale this up
by e to the Epsilon it will subsume the
other ellipsoid and if I scale it down
by e to the minus Epsilon it will be
completely inside the other loop sorry
okay good and in our PSD notation curly
less than equal to notation I can write
this succinctly as a is PSE less than e
to the Epsilon B
and a is PSD greater than e to the minus
Epsilon B this is just completely
equivalent
but slightly more compact notation
good so let's move with that so it turns
out to be a very nice relation let me
show you some very simple properties
that you can verify quickly
it's reflexive of course right like in
fact it's true with zero but any Epsilon
non-negative that's also
symmetric the way I defined it right
sometimes you'll see one plus Epsilon 1
minus Epsilon I chose to Define it as e
to the Epsilon so it turns so it's a
very it's a symmetric relation
you have additivity without loss in the
Epsilon so if I have A1 approximates B1
A2 approximates B2
A1 Plus A2 approximates B1 plus B2 the
same Epsilon
and here's the fourth one which is also
interesting it's transitive up to the
addition of error
if a approximates b b approximates uh
this should read C sorry uh if a
approximates b b approximate C then a
approximate C with the error being the
sum of the two
okay
all right question
I don't think you changed it the way you
want it
okay it's okay yeah but uh yeah you're
right sorry
approximate b b approximate C you get
a approximately
sorry about the typo
so what are spectral graft specifiers
let me Define it and then we will
interpret it right we say two graphs G
and H
that are graphs on the same vertex you
should really think of them as same
vertex set I will not say same size
really think of them as the same word
except so there's a mapping
we say that they that g
is a spectral or H is a spectral
specifier of n g if the laplacian's
approximate each other
right with Epsilon
I should point out I agree I'm using
Epsilon because I will usually think of
these as small but it's reasonable to
think of large Epsilon
right you can think of approximations
that scale like log n even n to the
n to the delta
right all of them on the the relation
still makes sense
it's non-trivial right but we say graphs
approximate each other
if the quadratic forms of the laplacians
right so the quadratic energy
is
is approximated for all vectors
right so if you think of laplacians as
your ellipsoids they are sandwiched
between small multiplicative copies of
each other how do you define it
you're saying that in that case ah good
in this case uh in this case X I say
that GA like these are spectral
sparsifiers
these are spectral glass parsippers I
mean these it's not sparse if H was
parse it would be
and if I'm able to show H that is much
sparseer than the graph I started with
that would be a spectral sparsifier
implication is a simple implication over
this definition gives you
let me pick my Vector X to be the
indicator Vector of a set s right so
this this Vector is one if you are
inside the set and 0 outside
we plug this in we get
by so look at the quadratic form what
happens to the coronation for a
quadratic form we add a sum for every
Edge
every Edge looks at the difference of
the two entries so if I have an edge
that's inside s both the entries are one
the contribution is zero if I have an
edge that's completely outside edge the
contribution is zero because both are
zero only the edge is crossing the set
one end point is in the set one is
outside will give you exactly
contribution one
so you will get
uh yeah this is what I would have
defined if I was doing triggers but now
let me Define it here you will get
the weight
in the graph edge of all edges so
plugging in X indicator of set here
you'll get weight in the graph edge of
all edges that go from s to the
complement of x all right so it's just a
sum over rates of the edges that are
crossing
and this is saying that for every cut
not just one for every cut
the cut value is approximate each other
question
h
okay thank you showing that
that I made this search very last minute
this should be G
right so
uh and they should be it
let me fix this sorry
okay
in line with debug
thank you
wait in G the cut value in G is
approximated up to
small multiplicative factors in the same
so every cut is approximate
right let me show you an example here so
here's a here's a graph I have two
size six clicks connected by a single
edge
right
and I'm for for example say let's focus
on two cuts here's one separating the
clicks which just this is
and here's one that's cutting two
vertices
and here I'm building a sparsifier for
them
it should preserve all cut the weights
of all the cuts right so if I look at
the cut that separates all of them
it's still one Edge so I don't have to
scale it I can just take the same weight
as the original one let's fix it
but here if I'm going to drop some edges
inside the click I have to scale up the
rest of the edges
right so that the sum total of the
weight Remains the Same
right I I started with 2 times 4 8 edges
here and here I only have six of them so
I have to scale them up by roughly four
thirds in order to get the same weight
this was a notion of cuts parsifiers
defined actually much before Spielman
show as well this was defined by Banks
uh 92 if I remember the people correctly
if somebody can confirm
right so they defined cuts parsifiers
objects that preserve all cuts
we are defining something stronger and
now two graphs where the laplacian is
preserved the cut preservation is an
implication
right and it turns out these two
spectral specification is actually
strictly stronger there are graphs where
it's known that you are you are a cut
sparsifier but not aspective specific
okay so let me formalize the result
we'll see today
for every graph
we present an algorithm which is
reasonably efficient but we won't worry
about that
we can find a reverted subgraph this is
this is a stricter notion than what I
introduced I just said graphs
approximate each other as long as the
laplaces are the same but now I'm saying
I will only use the edges in the
original graph but I'm allowed to re-way
them
but the edges with non-zero weight will
be much fewer now right like you could
start with quadratic number of edges and
I'll end up with a graph with only n
over Epsilon squared log n edges
so Epsilon is if Epsilon is constant n
log n edges
such that H is a specifier of t
a priority even the statement is
surprising right like when Bengal was
out it I I mean I wasn't around studying
Theory but I assume it was a big
surprise right that you could preserve
all Cuts with a much parser graph
in the in a similar way this this is
this was a very surprising like they had
proven it earlier using harder tools but
the existence of such parts of wires is
a surprise
right and today we'll show I'll show you
both an algorithm and essentially a
proof
how do you build these
question
however this depend on the fact that
this is the class here
good so great question let me repeat the
question the question is how much of
this applies to the fact that the mid
The Matrix you're starting with is a
laplacian would it apply to General code
right form it does apply to General
quadratic forms so if you have a sum of
several quadratic forms very many you
can show as long as the Matrix is PSD
you can show that there is a
distribution to sample from so that if
you sample n log n of those terms you
will get
Epsilon approximation
right so that so basically nothing here
applies you just need a PSD Matrix
and and like a rank one decomposition to
sample form
what's the best uh overhead
running time overnight or it's long to
the minus 2 login so is there a lower
bound good so Epsilon to the minus 2 is
tight yeah uh it comes from triggers
actually right like even for the clique
to get a Cuts pacifier I need
and the login is not tight even for
laplacians right so just the way you for
the click you can have constant degree
expanders
you will you can have
uh you can have for every graph it's
possible with n over Epsilon Square it's
a much trickier proof
[Music]
but you can achieve it
yes question yes oh sorry the question
was uh for General Matrix uh for General
matrices not laplacians will you get the
same dependence and approximation yes
you'll get e to the Epsilon
multiplicative approximation with the
same one over
n log n over Epsilon squared rank 1
terms or whatever like decomposition
factors
need a picture of Moses
inspiration valuability of a single
quadratic core
today this is not doable it's not like
if you just have a PSD Matrix you can't
sparsify the entries yeah
oh yeah let me yeah so so I let me reset
the question so thanks Adam so I think
this is the question so Adam is
commenting that there are slightly
different interpretations of what it
means to sponsify and let me say that
explicitly thank you so
when I said you can specify it what you
can do is you can write a PSD Matrix
approximately as a sum
of rank 1 factors in poly log if you're
if
if M was a sum of many poly many factors
let's say m was
sum over I2 no well rank would be
trivial because then n log n is much
larger right so very many
rank one terms v i v i transpose then I
can write an M tilde that is an
approximation which goes from I 1 to n
log n
and introduces away w i v i v i
transpose where I pick a subset of them
this in this sense you can achieve a
sparsification but if you are looking
for sparcification entry wise
right if I'm if I just write down an it
a matrix with N squared entries can I
have a sparse Matrix well many entries
are zero that's not true right while if
you want to achieve all multiplicative
currency
and it's and the example is very simple
if you look at the all ones
uh all ones rank one matrix it's
you will launch password
do you need the rank one here no you
don't
it's if if you don't mind we'll can we
drop the generalization questions for a
little later so that I can focus on the
graph's case if we have questions about
graph I'm happy to take them now I'm
happy to take the general questions in
the break too but I would like to make
sure we finish this
is a is the theorem statement cleared
all of us what are we hoping to build to
good so here's going to be our approach
the approach really seems deceptively
simple
so I'm going to define a random graph h
such that the following holes that in
expectation my laplacian of the random
graph is exactly equal to the laplacian
of the original graph
right and viewed as viewed as a matrix
so if you view the entries of the Matrix
it will end up being the set
the expectation of the random number
and two we will use Matrix concentration
don't worry if you haven't heard the
term before uh we will use Matrix
concentration to show that you can
achieve that that a randomly drawn
sample from
this distribution will approximate the
laplacian
right this is our high level approach
and of course I will spell out all the
details here but the plan is very very
simple I will Define a random graph with
the right expectation and show that it
concentrates
good so let's work with the easy part
the easy part is how do I Define
a distribution which achieves the right
expectation
here's what I'm going to do I start with
my original laplacian
it's a sum remember it was it's a sum
over edges
weight of the edges in the graph like
this e is this set of edges of G
weight of the edge times the laplacian
of the edge
and I'm going to sample a related
subgraph
that means I'm going to have the same
sum over edges
but now with new weights WV Prime where
many of them will be zero
times the LaPlace you know the same Edge
okay
and my sampling process is going to be
easy
I'm going to toss an independent coin
for every single edge
okay not probability half but a problem
specially chosen probability p e
specific to the edge
but every Edge I'll specify okay this
one I'll toss a coin with probability
one the other one I'll toss a coin with
probability point zero one right and I
will set so if the if the coin lands
head I would include the edge but with
the new weight w Prime
if the coin lands tells I will just
discard The Edge so the weight is zero
so what is my expectation for this
really simple process the expectation of
the laplacian
well it's an independent toss for every
Edge so I get a sum over edges the
probability that you see that you
actually pick the edge times the new
weight
e w e Prime Times the laplacian of the h
how many of you have never seen Matrix
random variables before
okay great so so one
one good way to just think of these is
that when I say that the expectations
are equal every single entry right so
expectation is linear so I can just look
at them entry wise
and an entry wise you get exactly the
sum on the right so I want to match both
of all the N squared entries on the left
and the right
but really because all of these uh like
the relations are linear expectation is
linear this one is actually very easy to
match
right do we all see how do we how do we
match the expectations
that's right thank you so we're going to
say the new weight
to be the old weight over the
probability of sampling so whenever you
sample it in expectation the multiplying
with the probability cancels out the 1
over P you get back to the original way
so this is called important sampling
Cross Independent coins with different
probabilities and whenever you keep the
object you scale It Up by 1 over p e and
this preserves the expectation
okay
so very easy this is my random graph
process
it's a distribution over graphs h
that achieves the right expectation
questions
we're doing the same thing right that's
right
in that sense that's right so so the
comment was about a random sampling for
banks
because I'm playing with the right
expectation exactly right
what the difference here will turn out
that in some sense
uh the achieving the probability
distribution is much cleaner here than
what makes your carbon
right and of course it ends up being
strictly Stronger Yeah
I think had a very nice proof
considering all the different Pi's PE
suggestions they all give the same
results
all the different PES that have been
used both by Steel menu
but
right uh yeah there was there was a
bunch there are a bunch of already
distributions I don't see their mother
here the Malaya is also
uh like a bunch of relative
distributions that will achieve
that will achieve this this one will
give you a certain specific one and in
fact probability is that any
probabilities that are larger than this
will work
that's the
that will work the next so you mentioned
that there are examples of graphs and
sports Fires for those graphs which are
kind of horse tires but not spectacular
yes I'm curious you know if you look at
the
Pro the probability is that the PES that
Benjamin Carter suggest are there also
examples where you know those PES don't
like using the edge strength or whatever
it is they use doesn't work First
Financial interesting question so
let me repeat the question the question
was
that we know examples where spectral
Sports there's a gra there are graphs
that are cut specifiers but not spectral
specifiers
is is it also true that that you see the
difference in the two sampling
distributions that pop out of these
these examples
I think you should see it but I'm not
entirely sure the example actually is
very simple you sort of have a
strengthened cycle
right you have a strong cycle uh
uh like with heavy edges and then you
have one Edge going diagonally across
and for this one for if if the edges are
if the if the cycle edges are strong
enough then then the edge going
diagonally across doesn't make a
difference for that specification
right but for spectral small segregation
you have to preserve this section
that's right I think it will show up in
because because the importance
probabilities of uh of the exactly are
basically defined by looking at the size
of
is not important for the size
oh sorry
it's a series of books uh with very nice
ways of
there are other probability
distributions simpler ones than what
banks are presented that achieves Cuts
classification
did you also achieve spectral
specification no right like so so for
spectral specification like this is the
lower bond that we
the lower bound that falls out of
out of stream
more questions
okay excellent good so then let's see
let's see the probabilities will pop out
of building the proof so let me build up
right we said the main key step of the
second process is showing Matrix
Constitution
what is Matrix concentration I will take
a very easy view it's not a
comprehensive view it's not a robust
view let me start with
scale our Channel bonds hopefully all of
you have seen them but let me remind you
of of churn of bounds for real random
variables right scalar one dimensional
random variables here's a particular
version so consider random variables x i
that are non-negative
and always bounded above by B okay
right they never take values larger than
b and they always take positive values
non-negative values
and let me assume
by some simple scaling that
there the expectation of their sum
or equivalently the sum of their
expectations is one
So Random variables that are bounded and
I know that their expectation is one
then with high probability for for a
second just read this term as with high
probability 1 minus vanishingly small
the sum is Epsilon close to one
and of course the key is what is this
probability as a function of my
variables it's 1 minus
2 e to the minus Epsilon square right if
you want an Epsilon approximation you
get an Epsilon squared divided by the
range of the variables
right this is a standard like it's just
so I'm I'll just massage some parameters
to write a standard scalar you don't see
it written this way you'll see typically
two like an upper tailbone a lower tail
bound with slightly different scalars in
both ways is I've just massaged it to
say that you get the sum lies between e
to the Epsilon e in e to the minus
Epsilon which is just roughly 1 plus
Epsilon 1 minus Epsilon with high
probability
and the interesting thing is how is this
probability scaling 1 minus E to the
minus Epsilon squared by the range of
the variables
this is scalar
scalar concentration how how many of you
have never seen scalar concentration
okay great so this is uh this is
familiar but just I'm rephrasing
something you've seen before now let me
present to you Matrix concentration
so there is an there is a version of
churn of bounds for Matrix random
variables that looks basically the same
so this version was proved by drop first
like they were older they were previous
versions that would have also worked for
the proof but drop has a very clean
version if you would like to see the
proof is also really very clean it uses
a powerful Matrix inequality but the
proof is really uses Matrix exponential
generating functions which is also how
you prove scalar concentration
so here's here's Matrix concentration uh
this is in some sense the Crux of the
algorithm in the proof so so
please stop me and ask questions if
anything is
so I will assume symmetric random
variables x i so these are now n by n
random matrices
that similar to before and now
PST right that PST greater than zero
and they all their eigenvalues are
bounded by B
right so they're spectrally bounded
by B times the identity Matrix
this is like this is the spectral
ordering right so or the other way to
think of is quadratic their quadratic
form is always between 0
and B times the norm of the vector
squared
X transpose
y transpose x i x
is at most B times the norm of Y squared
the assumption
assumption clear on the random variables
and I will do a similar scaling as
before I will assume that the sum
of their expectations is exactly equal
to the identity Matrix
right
so PSD random variables that are PSD
random Matrix variables that are always
bounded
and in expectation their sum is identity
these are my assumptions
then you get a statement that
generalizes the scalar one it says that
the sum of the random variables
is an Epsilon approximation of the
identity Matrix
in a PSD sense
with high probability
where the only thing you lose is that in
terms of the exponential decaying term
you get a factor of the dimension n
it's literally the same scaling Epsilon
my e to the minus Epsilon squared by B
but you get a factor of the dimension in
front of this Factor that's it it's like
it's like thinking of n independent
random variables and getting
concentration for all of them
right and if you did a union bound you
would lose exactly this n and this says
that's enough to get Spectral
approximation
it's a very surprising result because
if you were to try to prove this from
scratch you would think of oh let me
take an Epsilon net Over N Dimensions I
will get 2 to the N vectors and then uh
and and then you should lose an
exponential term here
right if you are going to Union bound
over every single Vector you would you
lose an exponential term
no because the eigenvectors of the
random variables need not align great
question let me repeat the question the
question was is it enough to work with
the eigenvectors and turns out no it
would be enough if all of these X I's at
the same eigen basis
but that's not true I'm not assuming
that the x i is commute I'm not assuming
they have the same algorithms
but still in effect
it's this concentration bound says that
the effect is the same
if they were commuting
that's what has to do with it because
proof of carcass thing right exploits
very much that there's only meal that's
right
uh good question so the question asks uh
in in benzo and cargo's original proof
they like even though there are
exponentially many Cuts they they work
with saying that the number of cuts sort
of increases polynomially with the size
so is there something similar here yes I
will give you a vague answer but I think
Jelani is the right so you can think of
these as like this sort of falls out of
what's known as chaining you look at a
sequence of Epsilon Nets where a very
coarse one and then a smaller one that's
closer and then a smaller one that's
closer and you be you basically have to
bound the growth of the sizes of these
Epsilon Nets which
if you squint hard enough is a
generalization of the polynomial growth
of cuts but but it's really a stretch to
say that these are the same arguments
it's much much harder here
yeah it's true
is somewhat related to the polynomial
growth of
I guess I'm just saying that the growth
of these different scales how do these
growth pops up both places that's the
only similarity
the number how do the number of cuts
grow and how do the number of vectors
grow with the like that growth shows up
buttons you have to squint really hard
yeah I should also point out that the
kinds of doubts you can get with chain
are strictly worse than what you could
hope to get by a more refined analysis
they're better versions of Matrix turn
off that exist and don't know changes
that recover stuff
good thank you I I will keep that
comment of the record so like so the
context is played yeah
the number of x i matrices in this bound
Excel no there is no dependence on the
number of
examples
yeah more questions about Matrix
concentration before we apply to a
random process
okay excellent so let's let me just
refresh this now if I wanted to achieve
high probability 1 minus 1 over n to the
C I mean let's say n to the 10. ah then
the bound I need on my random variables
looks like Epsilon squared over log n
and a factor
C you know like depending on how much
high probability you need
right for standard concentration you
would not have the login Factor
you only wanted everything to be smaller
than Epsilon over C and now you get
Epsilon over C Times log n
so if I have every random variable
every random Matrix is smaller than
Epsilon squared by log n
then I get
that it approximates the identity Matrix
with that probability
how do we apply this to our process
so let's recall what are our Matrix
random variables
we are going to have a random Matrix
variable for every Edge
so my random variable is as follows I
mean maybe you can think of this as x i
or x e for every Edge I get a random
variable
which takes the following values
with probability 1 minus p e is just the
zero Matrix
but with probability p e when I decide
to keep the edge
what do I contribute to my sum I
contribute the new weight which is the
old weight by the probability of
sampling
times the laplacian of the edge
right so the laplacian of the graph I
output is exactly the sum of
these random variables x i
questions
this is our definition of random
variables right
but this
is funny because
we wanted that the sum of their
expectations should add up to the
identity Matrix
but here the sum of the expectations
adds up to the original laplacian
you can fix this by a
pretty standard linear algebraic
transformation but if you haven't seen
it it might seem
magical you can fix this by multiplying
each Matrix x i on both sides with the
new with a matrix that's Deno that's
effectively the square root
inverse square root of the LaPlace
okay let me take a second to say how do
how should you think of this if you've
never if you've never seen this so
here
if I have a matrix m
inverse square root of the laplacian is
a matrix so that if I multiply if I
Square it multiply it by itself as a
matrix right I get the inverse
but how do you compute like this is an
existential question right but here's
another way to think of it if I was to
write the Matrix in terms of its eigen
decomposition Lambda i v i v i transpose
and for Simplicity just assume that all
the eigenvalues are non-negative
then
the m to the minus half Matrix just
applies the power minus r to the eigen
values 1 over root Lambda I
Vivi transpose
that's it and you can verify that
squaring this gives you 1 over Lambda I
which is the inverse of The Matrix
right so for every PSD Matrix
M there is a suitable m to the minus
half
a term sometimes can get thrown around
this is what's called whitening
you don't have to remember like you know
if you see it this is what is called
whitening the whitening
so if I multiply each of these samples
with l
plus inverse square root of the
laplacian of the original graph
then in expectation I get the identity
is singular
so yeah
thank you you didn't really want to hear
that thank you uh so so Philip is
pointing out well singular is a square
root of defined I am going to shove that
under the rug it's fixable yeah but it
actually needs massaging of the proof
also but you can you can sort of think
of it this way that there is an
orthogonal Direction Where each of these
matrices will have a kernel
so there is basically no Randomness in
the in the orthogonal side so I can just
work on this Subspace orthogonal to the
all one state right conceptually that's
enough but to make it formally work uh
it it would have made the proof a lot
more uglier
but uh the right thing to do here would
have been basically the square root of
the pseudo inverse yeah
okay I have a typo there this should
read sum of expectations
expectation the sum of these random
variable
s right now these are new random
variables that sum up to the identity
and
it's oh here's here's actually another
property that I did not
did not specify right so let's let me go
to the other side
um suppose
suppose you are able to prove that
LaPlace in G minus half laplacian of H
LaPlace you know G minus half
is Epsilon approximate the identity
this is in fact exactly equivalent to
proving that the laplacian of H
Quran approximates LaPlace energy
and and the way to do it is translate
the statement into quadratic form
and you get extra you get laplacian of G
minus half X
you define replace x with laplacian of G
half times y
and then the inverse is cancel you get
the quadratic form of H on the left hand
side and the quadratic form of G on the
right
but so it's a simple linear algebra
exercise
so it would suffice if I showed you
concentration for these random variables
questions
okay super so
let me here's a notation I like for
presentations you I I'm going to color a
random variable X
and say this is an isotropic position I
mean
whitened it's so Red X
is the laplacian minus half times the
original X LaPlace
okay I'll keep the definition up there
so that
so
we have a random variables so it should
be red x i
uh yes yes sorry
for every X this is just a definition
what is the Red X
We can question
okay we have but if you have a question
happy to
so
so in this notation we have summation of
expectations of these red variables is
exactly identity
so in order to apply so these are PSD
matrices
with their sum of expectations exactly
identity so in order to apply
concentration there's only one step
remaining is to bound their sizes and
bound the spectral Norms of these
random variables
right so we need to achieve that the
spectral Norm of the red variables is
smaller than Epsilon Square by log n I'm
going to ignore constants just for us
okay what is the norm of these variables
so whenever you there are only two cases
for every Edge right I if you don't
sample it it's the zero Matrix the norm
is zero driven so the question is when
you actually sample it and try to decide
to keep it what is the norm of the
sample right not of the expectation what
is the norm of the sample you drew so
the norm of the sample
is so the edge we included was a weight
w e by p e
right I I know I've not specified the
probabilities right but for every
probability we can do this analysis and
it will pop out what do the
probabilities need to satisfy to get
concentration
but so you get weight over the
probability
the laplacian of the edge
but because I'm looking at the isotropic
variables you have in a laplacia minus
half LaPlace
Norm of this
Matrix
we want this Norm with the weights to be
small
okay so now I'm going to do some linear
algebra trickery
uh the here is just a definition right
so we Define when we were defining the
laplacian of an edge we also observed
that it's a it's an outer product
of the vector 1u minus 1 V right a
vector that has one on U minus one on V
is 0 everywhere else and you get the
vector times the vector transpose so
just substitute that definition here
now this is a rank one Matrix right if I
view this as a vector right Vector Z
this is z times Z transpose
the norm of a rank one Matrix
right like it's a rank one Matrix it
only has one non-zero eigenvalue in the
direction of the rank one factor right
right so so it's Norm is basically the
same as its some
its Norm the largest eigenvalue is the
same as its sum of eigenvalues which is
the trace
right which allows you to apply cyclic
property of Trace
and get this as an outer product
but here's another way to think of it
rank one's matrices are very simple if
you have a rank on Matrix ZZ transpose
it's eigen leading eigenvalue is just
the norm of Z squared
right and it's eigenvector Z
so if I take so I get the norm of this
Matrix
and what is the sorry this vector and
what is the norm
it's the vector transpose times its
itself so you get one U minus 1 V
transpose LaPlace in inverse one U minus
1 V transpose
can I explain this manipulation let's
step again yeah so it's a rank one
Matrix z z transpose
we are looking at the norm of that
Matrix the num of that Matrix is exactly
the norm of Z squared Norm of the vector
Square which is e transpose Z
so I write I write z
sorry Z transpose The Matrix times
LaPlace and minus half LaPlace n minus
half times the vector and the minus
halves multiplied to give you the
inverse
so you get one U minus one B LaPlace in
inverse one U minus 1 V Q
yes
okay I want this
so it turns out this quantity one U
minus 1 V transpose laplacian minus one
Nu minus one V actually is a very nice
interpretation in terms of the graph
when you think of the graph as an
electrical Network
right
we we derived this yesterday that if I
have demands D my voltages are given by
the laplacian inverse times the demands
so this can be interpreted as I want
unit current into vertex U and draw it
out of V
multiplying it with the LaPlace in
inverse gives me the voltages in the
network
and then when I take an inner product
with again with one U minus 1B I get the
voltage difference across UV
so what is the voltage difference across
UV that will send one unit of current
and this is what is called exactly the
effective resistance of UV
it's like replacing the entire network
with just a single resistor across u and
v what is the size of that resistor is
given by the effective resistance
so what do we want we want
Like It suffices by a concentration to
pick the weight WV by P E times the
effective resistance is exactly the
expression that came out of the bound of
the norms to be like it smaller than
Epsilon squared by log n but I'll just
pick it to be Epsilon Square by log n to
pick the largest like
to get the smallest probability of
sampling map
and now I just rearrange it says that my
probability of sampling NH
is exactly proportional to the weight of
the edge times the effective resistance
multiplied by a log n over Epsilon
Square Factor
so every Edge
it's it's important it's proportional to
the wait times its effective resistance
right and just write pops out of the
need for applying Matrix turnovers
and once you pick these probabilities my
matrixion of bound goes through and you
get a proof that the laplacian of H with
LaPlace in original laplacian minus half
approximately identity which is the same
as saying that the two laplacians
approximate each other
yes
excellent so that is a caveat that I
cheated what's the question the question
is is it easy to see that the properties
are between as I Define them are between
0 1 they are actually not
I will and I will but I will give you a
fix of this the same proof is fixable
but for now just assume for some reason
that these were all always smaller than
one and it would be okay
right I will fix that but but before
that I'm actually going to show you
something else uh so
I mean
feet the motivation to get here was to
show that the eigenvalues are bounded
essentially that's right of the samples
yeah the motivation here was that in
order to apply
without it yes in order to apply Matrix
turn up I know I need my samples to be
always upper bounded by Epsilon Square
dollar
and that like the probabilities just
popped out of it
but specifically the eigenvalues have to
be the
okay so one more thing
the way times the effect of resistance
is often called The Leverage score pH
right effective resistance does not have
the weight
incorporated into it
but once you multiply it by the weight
then you get then it's called the risk
so here's another way to think of it for
zero weighted edges you still have an
effective resistance
but the leverage score is always zero
okay this is this is a definition of
unseen on often useful and we'll use it
in the second half
so there's just one step I need to wrap
up what is the number of edges we
sampled right right now I just showed
you oh if you pick these probabilities
you will get a concentration but if
that's all I wanted I would just keep
the graph right so I need to show that
in X you have sampled only a small
number of edges I'll just calculate the
expected number of edges you can make
this a high concentration bound but let
me just calculate the expected number of
edges with positive weight
so at least the summation is easy to
write sum over probabilities of keeping
the edge log n over Epsilon squared sum
of leverage scores which time effective
instances
now I need some more linear algebra let
me just this is just the definition of
effective resistances one U minus one V
transpose LaPlace in inverse one U minus
one V transpose
but this is a scalar
right one dimensional entry so I've just
introduced the trace operator here right
trace of a scale one dimensional Matrix
is just that entry
Trace has very nice properties Trace
allows you trace of a b is the same of
stress of B A you can sort of cycle
around the entries
uh without uh like while preserving the
trace exactly so I'm going to apply two
properties of the trace first linearity
so by linearity I can bring the weight
in
do I have another step here yes I think
I do good
so I I'm going I'm going to use
linearity to bring the summation inside
and I'm going to use the cyclic property
of the trace so by cyclic property I'm
going to first move this Vector out here
so this Vector here that gives me 1u
minus 1 V 1 U minus 1 V transpose
right and and that sort of isolates the
laplacian on one side
I guess the way the way I've done it is
you take this vector and put it at the
end so the laplacian comes up front the
first second and third
so the laplacian I can pull out by
linearity
the second and the third entries are
here and the scalar I've pulled in again
with linearity somewhere
some over edges weights one U minus one
V one U minus one V transpose
this is exactly my original laplacian
so this is just the trace of Laplace in
inverse times the laplacian which is
identity so it's bounded by n n over
Epsilon squared log
so in expectation I have only sampled n
over Epsilon squared log n edges
right
yes
excellent I will
so the question was can you compute
these effective resistances quickly
efficiently then they can be computed in
polytime this
but you can actually compute them really
really fast
on your time
but let me let me drop that question
maybe to later right like the key piece
is to be able to solve linear systems in
the LaPlace and fast that we'll see in
the second part of the talk you combine
that with Johnson Linden straws and
you're able to estimate them really in M
poly login time you can estimate all of
them rather than just one
and that suffices to get the
probabilities quickly and then you can
draw
spots
okay and I
like this is the end of my part the end
of the first part of caveat that I
that I didn't uh that was raised uh was
that the way I've defined these
probabilities it can be larger than one
but let me tell you you can do this
without loss of generality
why if I split one Edge into K parallel
edges with weights that are scaled down
by K
w e by K
then each of these has a leverage score
that's smaller by a factor one over k
you can basically treat them as
different edges
nowhere in the proof did I assume that
there were no parallel edges
so you can have parallel edges with
smaller weight and their leverage score
goes down
and it does not affect the output the
output of the procedure or the
concentration probability
right so just divide each Edge into
login copies each of them gets a
leverage score of one hour login and now
you can apply the same probabilities
the same proof goes through
but it turns out actually with a
slightly more involved proof you can
just do the following that you just keep
all edges if your probability this
expression is larger than one just keep
it deterministically and do not do any
sampling but the proof is trickier like
you have to you have to work with the
randomness
okay I think that's that person you get
an extra Factor we'll log in and this
person in the sparsity bar no
so my sparsity bar was completely
independent of how many edges I started
with
right my sparsity bound that I achieved
was just n log n independent of whether
I started with N squared or in fact n to
the 10 where many of them are parallel I
don't care
you will end up only with n log n edges
right that's why that's why this really
is a it's a complete proof you'll
usually not see this because because you
can just ignore and not do random
sampling on the ones that get queued
larger probabilities but the proof is
but the proof needs more work
foreign
[Applause]
with the same number of addresses
excellent question uh the question is is
there a deterministic algorithm with the
same kind of wrong yes big uh if you are
willing to pay a lot more in running
time
because you can basically compute all
the like you can execute the proof of
Matrix concentration quite explicitly
but the runtime blows up to a large
polynomial Factor
to do it efficiently I think you need
almost linear time to produce any kind
of specifiers and I don't think you can
achieve uh like you need m to the
OnePlus Epsilon running time and in 5
gram to the OnePlus Epsilon edges to do
it completely deterministically
good so
you need almost linear number of edges
if you wanted your entire algorithm to
be we don't know if you wanted your
entire algorithm to be deterministic we
don't know of an almost linear time
algorithm that generates a specifier
with n poly logins
just asking it
I'm saying
the only deterministic is easy because
you can just compute all the matrices
very explicitly
in polynomial type yes sorry I I thanks
thanks so you can do it in like large
polynomial time deterministically
because you can execute the entire proof
of
of the Matrix concentration bound and
converted into what's called pessimistic
estimators basically track the trace and
pick the best options so you can do it
in large polynomial time to get the same
proof
but if you wanted like really efficient
algorithms we do not know something
matching this Varsity so I even met
there's BSS yeah this is
good thank you I mean but it's the same
same running time complexity they also
work with traces of matrices you do the
same here so
it's on that fantastic open problem well
we'll end the the session for now uh
we'll have a break until uh 11 o'clock
and then we'll come back to the top so
let's thank sushant again
[Applause]